former Special Counsel Robert Moe Asch
testimony had lawmakers in both parties
claiming victory as promised Muller
pointed to his written report to answer
many questions yesterday and he was
frequently concise he gave one-word
responses 176 times
Moeller emphasizes investigation did not
exonerate President Trump of potential
crimes including obstruction he said
repeatedly that Justice Department
guidelines prevent a sitting president
from being indicted but he said that
does not mean mr. Trump would have been
charged otherwise President Trump
criticized Muller's testimony and he
claimed victory the performance was
obviously not very good he had a lot of
problems but what he showed more than
anything else is that this whole thing
has been three years of embarrassment
and waste of time for our country after
the hearings House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
stood firm on her beliefs that Democrats
should fight the president in court and
not through impeachment Virginia
Democratic Senator Mark Warner is the
vice chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee that committee is
investigating Russian interference in
the 2016 election and he joins us now
from Washington in his first TV
interview since the Moller hearing
senator good morning good morning
you have not meant among those members
of your party calling for an impeachment
inquiry did what you saw and heard
yesterday changed the calculation for
you it didn't change the calculation I'm
gonna leave that to Speaker Pelosi where
we've been focused is the point that Bob
Muller made repeatedly yesterday not
only did Russia attack us in 2016 but
they will be back in 2020 and candidly
what I'm amazed at I got no interest in
relitigate in 2016 I am interested in
making sure that we have appropriate
protections in place in 2020 let's make
sure there's a law that says if a
foreign government tries to intervene
tell the FBI let's make sure every
ballot that's cast in 2020 has a paper
ballot back up let's make sure we take
bipartisan legislation we've got so that
if a foreign government intervenes
we immediately slap sanctions on
and let's also try to make sure that
we've got some rules of the road on
social media so that people can know
when they're hearing from a human being
versus a bot when we have the same kind
of political disclosure for political
ads on the web that we have on TV this
is fairly common sense why partisan
stuff and my hope would be that leader
McConnell and this White House would
agree to bring this kind of legislation
to the floor we shall see
senator President Trump called the
Muellers testimony a disaster for the
Democrats yesterday so a couple of
things I want to know what you thought
about his testimony yesterday and what
did the Democratic Party accomplish if
anything out of these hearings well
candidly I was working that yesterday
and only got a chance to KITT big catch
big bits and pieces of the testimony
well the businesses you saw what did you
think well he had told us beforehand he
was gonna stick to the script that he
was not going to go outside the four
corners of the report he did that I
think you know anyone who expected
bombshells on either sides didn't get it
but I keep coming back to what I thought
was you know not in the relitigated of
2016 but in how we protect ourselves the
fact that he said not only are Russians
coming back to attack but they are
literally attacking us each and every
day I would hope that every American I
don't care where you fall on a partisan
scale would take that as a warning and
recognize that same message is coming
out of Donald Trump's own director the
FBI chris ray it's coming out of Trump's
own Director of National Intelligence
dan coats in this ought to be a national
security issue and what again bothers me
is this president seems so obsessed
about his own kind of a personal
well-being that he dismisses this threat
and frankly when he goes to a g20
meeting and makes light of this issue
with Vladimir Putin he does not make our
nation safer senator speaking about the
president there you said earlier this
year that there were enormous amounts of
evidence of a conspiracy between the
Trump campaign and Russia
Robert mullah reiterated again yesterday
that he did not find that so given your
earlier comments and given what's in the
report do you
the president an apology the we are
still finishing our counterintelligence
investigation we still have not gotten
access to literally reams of
counterintelligence evidence and I
believe what mr. Muller said yesterday
at least what was reported to me was he
said they didn't even look at collusion
because collusion is not a legal
terminology they did say there were well
over a hundred contacts between Russians
and individuals in the Trump campaign
and as somebody who's been around
certain presidential campaigns in the
past that's just not normal
but senator with all due respect the
report does say that collusion and
conspiracy are functionally synonymous
and conspiracy was not established by
the evidence I am NOT here to try to
relitigate Moeller's conclusions I am
here to make sure that we are safe in
2020 and unless we pass additional
legislation unless this White House in
Mitch McConnell allows these bills to
come to the floor bills that would get
75 80 votes we're not doing all we can
to protect our process the latest poll
from CBS shows most Americans are ready
they've had it up to here with the
Mullen report they're ready to move on
do you agree yes or no wasn't I've been
on this for the last couple years our
investigation has got to finish I think
you moving on from whether we really
relitigate 2016 is one issue making sure
that we're safe in 2020
I think Gail I've seen those very same
polls who the vast majority of Americans
agree the Russians intervened and when
you've got Donald Trump's own FBI
director director of National
Intelligence and now Bob Muller
continuing to say they will be back and
they are attacking us on a day-to-day
basis I would think I'd be anxious to
hear from any of my colleagues why they
wouldn't support the kind of
common-sense plans and legislation I
outlined earlier in the interview all
right senator Warner we thank you for
taking the time we really appreciate it